I'm Sean Duffy in for Lord Ingram and
this is a special edition of the Ingram
angle
all right first this is Biden's America
people are getting poorer and growing
more desperate by the day this one
headline from the Associated Press sums
it all up long lines are back at U.S
food banks as inflation hits high and it
gets worse a Louisiana Food Bank CEO
warns that right now there's enough food
but that might not be the case in the
future citing High fuel costs making it
more expensive to collect and distribute
the food Americans who need help right
now are in a perilous position
I'm not making ends meet I'm not making
it I'm setting my savings
um
I get paid tomorrow and already my whole
paycheck is spoken for and it's the
first time in my life I've had to apply
for food stamps because I don't know how
we're going to continue eating groceries
I gave four gas sometimes so you eat or
buy gas
that's the way it goes now and it
shouldn't be like that in America
no it shouldn't but this is Biden's
America
this is the United States of America for
God's sake we can't deal with that
guess not now at the time bite I made
those comments we were all about a year
into the pandemic so many people were
out of work businesses had closed and
yes there were long lines at food banks
but it was getting better the
unemployment rate was slowly going down
the economy was rebounding president
Trump handed Biden a country that was
getting back on his feet but that all
changed and this desperation felt on the
part of many Americans came back all due
to the policies that the Biden
Administration has put into place
so knowing that Americans are truly in
trouble how is the White House and its
Dem allies responding to all this
we got a long way to go because of
inflation because of the I call it the
Putin tax increase Republicans do
nothing to obstruct our efforts to lower
your gas taxes inflation Springs from
higher costs higher costs bring from
shorter Supply shorter Supply is there
because of covet preventing certain
products from coming into our country it
is because in large part right now
because of this energy crisis
so is this because of Putin covid the
supply chain I'm having trouble keeping
track these excuses keep piling up but
the solutions are never anywhere to be
found perhaps the most heroic effort
we've seen as of late came from
congresswoman Veronica Escobar who was
discussing Biden's Balancing Act of
Killing oil and gas exploration in the
U.S with begging a murderous dictator
for some of his oil
the president is juggling some historic
uh challenges right now he inherited a
country and that was grappling with
covid we now are seeing Global inflation
decades ago we should have acted far
more quickly to transition away from
fossil fuels because we haven't made
that transition we're reliant on uh on
gas no one should Envy the position that
President Biden is in right now hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else